[Music]
on this Sunday night America's
unprecedented week ahead Trump ready for
battle as the former U.S president gets
set to surrender to authorities he's
someone who's going to be ready for this
fight we're ready for this fight plus
security ramps up as Trump's base rolls
[Music]
rolled Letty aftermath that is
to say that killed a popular pro-russian
blogger
turbulent times why air travel is on the
federal government's radar the airports
need money lots of it how the cost of
your next flight is set to soar and
Mission To The Moon we're about to
announce which one of them is going to
go to the Moon I mean it's it's historic
we're one on one with Canada's best
known astronaut ahead of tomorrow's
Artemis 2 announcement
[Music]
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us first to the Calm before the
unprecedented political storm as
anticipation builds up ahead of Donald
Trump's arraignment coming days after
Trump was indicted marking the first
time in American history that a former
president has faced criminal charges
Trump is expected to fly in a private
plane to New York tomorrow before he
surrenders to authorities in Manhattan
on Tuesday Trump's lawyer says the
former president will fight any charges
related to those hush money payments
vigorously
he's gearing up for a battle
um you know this is something that
obviously we believe is a political
persecution and he's someone who's going
to be ready for this fight
Trump announced today that he will speak
from his Mar-A-Lago Resort in Florida
following his first hearing Reggie
cicchini has our top story tonight
there is no precedent for how this
arraignment will unfold and while it
will be carefully choreographed it will
also be making history with each step
former president Donald Trump will
remain at his Mar-A-Lago estate in
Florida until Monday when he's then
expected to fly to New York and
overnight at his residence in Trump
Tower in Midtown Manhattan before
traveling by Secret Service motorcade to
the courthouse on Tuesday Morning a
building already behind layers of
security fencing and Gates the charges
Trump faces reported to be in the dozens
are still unknown but there is a push by
large media outlets in the U.S to have
them unsealed ahead of time along with a
similar move to allow cameras inside the
courthouse to capture Trump's arrival he
is expected to plead not guilty and
while he will be processed it's unclear
if a mug shot will be taken the former
president is rallying support both
within his base and with his Republican
allies who argue this is nothing more
than a Witch Hunt phrasing Trump has
used for years I'm commit attempts by
democrats to go after perceived
wrongdoing legal experts however say
while there may be difficulties with the
New York attorney general pursuing
federal charges claims from within
Trump's Inner Circle that this is a
partisan effort appear unfounded despite
all the noise
um there's no evidence uh suggesting
that this is a political prosecution
there's no evidence suggesting that
there are other people who committed
similar offenses that Manhattan
prosecutors decided not to prosecute
Trump is using this indictment to his
Advantage with his campaign claiming
it's raised four million dollars in the
last several days Reggie Global News
Washington
the death toll is growing in the wake of
those powerful tornadoes that carved a
path of Destruction across several U.S
states on Friday night at least 26
people are now known to have died the
White House confirmed today that it will
provide Federal resources including
financial assistance to support ongoing
recovery efforts after President Joe
Biden's disaster declaration residents
in the seventh Southern and Midwestern
states that were hit hard are reeling as
they begin the cleanup sifting through
what's left of their homes and wider
communities more than 60 tornadoes were
recorded in one night including a major
twister that tore through Arkansas's
capital of Little Rock
a prominent Russian military blogger has
been killed in an explosion in Saint
Petersburg vladian tatarsky has died and
at least 25 others were injured in the
blast this afternoon tatarsky was a
strong supporter of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine last year he said that Russia
will defeat everyone kill everyone and
Rob everyone Redmond Shannon reports
most uh just before he was killed
someone handed vladlin tatarsky a statue
as a gift Russian media is reporting
that the bomb was hidden inside the
Statue moments later a video purportedly
shows the explosion from outside the
Saint Petersburg Cafe inside a bloody
aftermath that injured two dozen but
only killed tatarsky
he was a Russian military blogger who
strongly supported the kremlin's
invasions of Ukraine to tarsky whose
real name was Maxim fomin was born in
Soviet Ukraine in 1982 when President
Vladimir Putin held a ceremony to Annex
four regions of Ukraine last year
including tatarsky's birthplace of
Donetsk he recorded a selfie video at
the Kremlin
he said we will defeat everyone we will
kill everyone we will rob everyone just
as we like
Russian authorities are calling the
blast terrorism with one kremlin-backed
official in Ukraine already blaming Kiev
an advisor to Ukraine's Vladimir
zelenski is framing it as Russian
domestic terrorism tatarsky had been
critical of Russian military commanders
as the war dragged into a second year a
local media Outlet in Saint Petersburg
says the bombed Cafe was previously
owned by yevgeni pragosian he is the
head of the Wagner mercenary group
fighting for Russia in Ukraine The
Killing comes seven months after a
Moscow Car Bomb killed Daria dugina the
daughter of a prominent Russian
nationalist a killing that Russia blamed
on Ukraine but that Kiev also denied
Redmond Shannon Global News London
now to the U.S Canada border in southern
Quebec police have identified two of
eight bodies recovered from the Saint
Lawrence River Following last week's
boat tragedy as they continue to search
for a man that is still missing
officials in aquasazny identified two
family members of Romanian descent a
woman and a man both 28 years old the
man was carrying the Canadian passports
of his two children the identities of
four Indian Nationals have not yet been
released police have intensified their
search for aquasazne Resident
30-year-old Casey Oaks who's considered
a person of interest he was last seen on
Wednesday night operating a boat found
next to the bodies police believe the
two families were trying to cross into
the U.S illegally from Canada when their
boat capsized in stormy weather on
Wednesday night
there is an alarming Trend rising in
Canadian cities seemingly random and
sometimes deadly attacks in transits
that have taken the headlines in cities
like Toronto and Vancouver commuters
across the country are concerned for
their safety Julia Foy reports on what
could be driving this rash in violence
a sunny Saturday morning bus ride in
Surrey BC was shattered When a Stranger
slashed the neck of a passenger with a
large kitchen knife the victim was
rushed into surgery and is expected to
survive a suspect is in custody facing
possible charges of attempted murder but
investigators are still searching for
answers on why this happened one
criminology expert has a theory people
are
worried they're afraid they feel
isolated
they're carrying knives either because
they're angry or they're fearful
the Surrey assault comes just a week
after 16 year old Gabriel magalis was
stabbed to death as he waited in a
Toronto Transit station
I just did myself here on the floor and
I just looked like I was like tell me
tell me I know what happened just say it
police believe Gabriel's attack was
unprovoked 22-year-old Jordan O'Brien
Tobin is charged with first degree
murder
Morton suspects the people who attack
others are suffering from mental health
issues they may be attracted to negative
social media streams and this can lead
some to believe the world is
destabilized which can steal their hope
for a better future people are getting
knifed over
accidentally bumping into somebody else
or telling teenagers to stop being brats
throwing stuff around that's a very bad
sign in a society concerns about the
pandemic the war in Ukraine and the
rising cost of living are raised as
issues that have affected the Public's
mental health but Morton says there is a
way to help as a society in all regards
our schools our churches our community
groups our social networks we need to be
encouraging one another to go out and
visit with other people do things out of
our houses and a bit of advice for
everyone turn off the computer or put
down the cell phone and go out and do
something with other people Julia Foy
Global News
last year's summer travel season was
frustrating this one may be even more
expensive coming up how much airport
fees are expected to rise for your next
flight
[Music]
Canadian swimming sensation summer
Macintosh is Making Waves at the
national swimming trials and I get this
she's only 16 but she powered her way to
a world record time in the world's 400
meter individual medley on Saturday and
then earlier in the week she said a new
world best in the women's 400 meter
freestyle Macintosh is the first swimmer
ever to hold world records for both
races at the same time
it's been an extremely turbulent time
for Airlines and passengers but the
federal government has revealed it has
air travel on its radar last week Ottawa
laid out a plan in its federal budget to
speed up airport security and screening
times to reduce those lengthy flight
delays exacerbated by coven 19.
Mackenzie gray looks at the problems and
what Ottawa is now promising
after a year full of disastrous delays
at airports across the country the
Liberals are trying to avoid the same
fate for the upcoming summer travel
season
in the recent budget the feds proposed
1.8 billion over five years to help the
Canadian Air transport security
Authority improve passenger screening
and strengthen security measures at
airports one of the key issues in last
year's delays
an affordable economy and a healthy
future the cash could be a start to
stabilize Canadian Air Travel the
airports need money lots of it a lot
more than what is in this budget in
order to fix the problem and that's
where passengers come in to help fix
those problems with the feds announcing
for the first time in 13 years airport
fees will increase for a one-way
domestic flight airport levies are
jumping to 9.94 for international travel
the cost will soar to over 35 dollars
it's an average increase of 33 percent
the airports seem to have you know put a
lot of money on the front talking to
customers not much in the back and I
think that's where that's where it's
falling apart but getting through
security quickly is little Solace to
passengers if their flight is delayed or
canceled the budget reiterated an
earlier pledge from the transport
minister to change the airline passenger
Bill of Rights which outlines
compensation the airlines must pay when
there are flight interruptions but
carriers often use loopholes to avoid
paying their cost
the current system is not simply unfair
to passengers but it is also unworkable
the NDP have proposed changes to the
Bill of Rights to align Canadian
regulations with the European Union the
Liberals have had three years to get
this right when the regulations came out
in 2019 they promised they were going to
be the best in the world and yet we see
other jurisdictions like the European
Union who have far stronger air
passenger protections than we do the
Canadian Transportation agency which
adjudicates disputes between passengers
and Airlines says they have a backlog of
over 40 000 complaints and they warn it
could take years to get through far up
and lots of frustration for consumers in
that time Mackenzie gray and Ottawa
thank you Mackenzie
I had triple election night in Europe
the country's going to the polls plus
why Canada paying close attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Pope Francis leads Palm Sunday mass in
St Peter's Square today only hours after
leaving the hospital where he was
treated for severe bronchitis the 86
year old pontiff opened the mass with a
weak and slightly breathless voice and
then thanked people for their
participation and prayers which
intensified these past few days while he
was recovering in Rome
elsewhere in Europe Unity was on the
ballot in Finland Bulgaria and
Montenegro tonight which the Trudeau
government argues is crucial for
Canadian Security and prosperity and
there's now already a change to the
political landscape in two of those
countries because in Finland and
Montenegro the incumbents lost our chief
political correspondent David Aiken
walks us through what's at stake
the partnership between Canada and the
EU is stronger than ever the Trudeau
government wants a United Europe for
Canada's security and prosperity
but maintaining European unity in the
face of Russian aggression
is no easy thing the very values that
unite us
are challenged today like never before
indeed in three countries at Europe's
Edge hundreds of thousands of Voters
cast ballots Sunday for some candidates
who reject a pan-european vision and for
others that are openly sympathetic to
Russia
in Finland the government of social
Democrats Santa Marine fell in a tight
three-way race a center-right party won
the most seats but the even
writer-leaning populist Finn's party now
holds the balance of power and it favors
pulling back from the European Union
well of course we are going to defend
our our goals and our values but there
is only a coalition government possible
in Finland so it's always a compromise
Montenegro is already a NATO member but
the long-serving pro-western incumbent
president Milo yukonowicz Was Defeated
after 32 years in power the new
president Jacob militovich is supported
by some pro-russian parties even though
he favors European union membership I
believe that we are entering a new era
for Montenegro and era for a better uh
more just more wealthy as well as more
democratic Montenegro European and in
Bulgaria pro-western parties won the
most votes but a populist and
pro-russian party finished third it
increased its standing and its influence
in that country's politics David Aiken
Global News
Ottawa
the excitement surrounding tomorrow's
Artemis 2 announcements who will be the
next Canadian heading to space for a
one-on-one with retired astronaut Chris
Hadfield next
in less than 24 hours we will learn the
Artemis 2 crew of four astronauts
scheduled to fly around the Moon next
year the first crude mission of its kind
in half a century and one will be a
Canadian picked from the country's pool
of four active astronauts that work
alongside NASA in Houston the contenders
are Joshua from Alberta a Canadian
fighter pilot recruited by the Canadian
space agency Jeremy Hansen from Ontario
who became a pilot at age 17 and is the
first Canadian in charge of training
astronaut candidates at Nasa Jennifer
Sydney Gibbons from Alberta the youngest
of the group and a former lecturer at
the University of Cambridge in the UK
and a familiar face Quebec's David
sanjak who flew to the ISS in the
longest Canadian space mission to date
joining me now to talk about this
upcoming announcement is retired
Canadian astronaut Chris Hadfield who is
also a busy author lately he's working
on a new thriller a cold war Thriller
called The Defector it's coming out
later on this year as if being an
astronaut wasn't enough Mr Hadfield
thanks so much for joining us
um I want to get right to it
I want to get right to it tomorrow uh
we're going to hear this announcement
you were involved in selecting these
four names and I don't think you're
gonna give me who you think is best but
let me ask you this
um what is NASA and what is the Canadian
space agency looking for for this
specific role
those those four names you just
mentioned those are some terrific
Canadians some some amazingly
accomplished and driven and and
hard-working uh Canadian astronauts who
have been serving the country for a long
time so I am just so excited that we're
about to announce which one of them is
going to go to the Moon I mean it's it's
historic no one has ever left Earth
orbit except an American what we're
looking for of course is what those four
astronauts have and that is deep
technical competence a great ability to
deal with problems and solve them and
make things work
um a real burning desire to work at this
thing it's going to take years of work
and they're going to have to take a
tremendous risk to climb on board that
enormous rocket ship that's only ever
flown once in history and take that
little spaceship all the way around the
Moon and back and then uh the last thing
I think is a great ability to work
during their entire life
trusting their lives and having the
skills to be trusted with other people's
lives in close proximity for for decades
as as they get ready for a flight like
this so we've got the right people any
of the four of them can do it but
tomorrow we're going to find out which
one
it's such an exciting announcement
because these astronauts will also
travel faster than any humans ever have
they'll also be going further from Earth
than anyone so what kind of training
will this crew be doing in this mission
to prepare for that
the the mission itself far will be about
10 or 11 days long and they're going to
launch out of Florida so a large part of
their training of course is the launch
vehicle and all the various things that
go wrong during launch and how you can
survive it how you can do different
things to to overcome those problems
then they're going to stay in Earth
orbit for several days while they check
everything out they make sure all of the
systems work all of the the complexities
of navigation and all of the life
support systems you know it's a brand
new vehicle and someone needs to do the
initial big test flight on it and then
they're gonna fire the great big engine
that as you say will get them faster
than anybody's ever gone before so that
they can go all the way up to the moon
and it's as if we were rowing a stone so
fast that it would go all the way to the
moon and they get caught by the moon's
gravity and whip around the other side
and then fall 400
000 kilometers until it plummets back
into the atmosphere and they have to be
able to operate in the machine during
all of that that and of course coming
back down through the atmosphere where
the air slows them down so it's it's a
huge Suite of skills and and potential
risks that they need to get ready for
let's talk about settlement on the moon
do you think we're going to see humans
live on the moon in our lifetimes
initially someone has to take the risk
to just show you can get there but then
your technology gets good enough that
you can actually start staying longer
and longer and really making that part
of the whole Human Experience the Earth
Moon economic system so yeah that's
what's going on right now the early
steps towards not just exploration but
permanent human presence and settlement
and that's what this Canadian and there
are three American crewmates are signing
up to do
so I can count that as a yes in our
lifetime we think this could happen
yes well it depends how long how long
you're planning to live Farah but I'm
sure plan it'll live long enough to see
it yeah that's coming very fast and of
course it's not just Canada not just the
United States but there are 77 countries
that have space agencies this is the
start of a big International effort and
there'll be some competition in there so
yeah that's another reason to answer
your question yes sure is exciting thank
you so much for your time and of course
your Insight retired Canadian astronaut
Chris Hadfield
and that's golden National for this
Sunday night I'm foreign on behalf of
our whole crew here I want to thank you
so much for spending part of your
evening with us this Sunday tonight's
your Canada is this group of comrants
alongside a white pelican in Regina
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]